[Musique]
voir les enfants pour soi
quelle foi nounours ne vous inquiétez
pas petit ami notre nounours est un peu
mélancolique ce soir repos
profondément patron
regardez la mine que j'ai j'ai d'être
tiru la truffe des fêtes les yeux cernés
le poids triste or nous ce n'est plus
possible
je travaille trop allons descente a misé
un moment ça te fera du bien et celles
ont toujours
aux
hommes pop hip hop hop hop hop hop hop
bonsoir
crocos qui se regarde dans un miroir
je préférerais ne pas me voir avec la
triste mine que j'ai
vraiment remis auger mauvaise mine je
savais
qu'elle est ravie
qu'il est très bas mais oui je suis pas
mal je le sais je ne me sens pas bien
bas monde renonce nous allons nous
occuper toi oui je vous en prie allant
de faire beau et aura pas de mine vous
croisez gens tous
nous
calmer bon dieu que nous
ferme les yeux nous
va être bon ouvre la bouche là un petit
peu de rouge
maintenant je passe du rouge à lèvres
encore un peu
ou
[Musique]
si je fais un beau chapeau rouge pas là
un peu de noir sur la tête
une chatouille la druance que tu vas
en france mais avec le japon s'il tombe
tout le temps un clou dans ma tête mais
vous êtes fous je cours
pas drôle aujourd'hui
merci je vais très bien je sens que j'ai
très bonne mine bonne nuit
[Rires]
[Musique]
et
ouf et ton miroir nounours je les
oubliez pas trop mais je n'irai pas le
rechercher ce soir d'ailleurs je me sens
beaucoup mieux j'en suis bien content
pour toi ma force de caractère au trio
fut
halo rose
bonnet des enfants faites votre toilette
n'oubliez pas de vous laver les dents
embrasser bien fort vos parents
vous
oh
[Musique]
e